Literally in a literal,
exact or actual sense,
not figuratively or allegorically.
The primary definition of the word
literally literally used to indicate that
some metaphorical or hyperbolic
will expression is to be
taken in the strongest,
admissible since
virtually or figuratively.
Second definition of the word literally.
And it's that second definition that
grammar prescriptive is seemed to be
uncomfortable with.
So in defense of that second definition,
meaning figuratively or virtually allow
me to present a case for literally the
first argument of the prosecution states.
But isn't it impossible for literally to
retain its original meaning so long it
is being used to express the opposing
idea and won't having two opposing
definitions caused confusion.
Actually,
English has quite a few words that
simultaneously cold what meaning and its
polar opposite. They're called
Auto Antonyms or conference.
For example,
I can cleave a tree in two with my ax
or as genesis suggests I can cleave unto
my wife.
One definition means to divide while
the other definition means to bring
together, despite having one word
with two opposing definitions.
Both definitions have remained intact
and given the fact that context among
other things helps to determine meaning
and the beauty and confusion are
unlikely.
I submit that literally like many
other auto antonyms such as dusting the
furniture by removing dust,
but dusting a cake by adding dust can
maintain both definitions while still
maintaining low levels of ambiguity.
The second argument of the prosecution
states that the original definition of
the word literally is in an actual
sense and therefore if you use it in any
other way, you're using
it wrong. First of all,
we're definitions are constantly changing.
It's a part of language and it's a part
of life. The word meats, for example,
did not always refer to
this flesh of animals.
It used to be a general word to describe
any edible non liquid substance much in
the same way we use the word food today.
It's true that the original
definition of the word means actually,
but the other definition of the
word used as an intensifier,
which we'll talk about later,
is used in figurative situations.
And as much as a handful of
snooty grammar prescriptive,
this would like to have control over how
people speak. It is in fact the masses,
not the pretentious few who ended
up deciding the fate of a language.
I submit that even if the dictionary
did not include this second definition,
which it does literally have more than
one valid definition because we as a
people have given it more than one.
So while the original meaning of literally
is in an actual sense of the word,
has since broken out of that original
meaning literally can now mean
figuratively and it's commonly employed,
has an intensifier and intensifiers a
word that has little semantic content of
his own, but as used to intensify
the meaning of a word or phrase,
which it modifies.
A couple of examples of intensifiers
are so as an I'm so tired and dead as in
your dead wrong,
very agreeably are also intensifiers.
But unlike so in dead very and really
have quite a bit in common with literally
vary from the England Norman [inaudible]
with the modern French word for play
used to have the meaning of truly or
actually and really coming from the word
real had a similar meeting.
Now both words are often
just use as intensifiers
although the original meanings
of the words are still employed
in some context. When do you say,
I'm really excited.
You don't mean that in all reality
or truthfulness you are excited.
You mean my level of excitement surpasses
that of just being plain excited.
I'm really excited.
I submit that literally is taking,
it's rightly deserve place as an
intensifier in the English language and it
cannot be judged based solely on its
original meaning and the final argument of
the prosecution states.
This is just a modern corruption
of the English language.
I guess everything is relative
but considering the fact
that using literally in
a non literal sense has been around for
longer than the United States itself.
I wouldn't necessarily call this a
modern corruption and tell next time.
I'm literally going to bite the head
off of the next person that says,
I'm using literally wrong.
Um, well, I think that was,
come on.